bob saget's daughter shares a text from
her dad just hours before his tragic
death
carlton
patient will be in room 962.
it's going to be for a male patient
tyler's advising it's the obvious
destinating or security officer phone
guest not breathing no pulse shortly
after news broke that the full house
star and comedian died his eldest
daughter aubrey saget posted this
screenshot to her insta story a brief
but touching text message she received
from her late dad reading simply thank
you love you show time when you care
about somebody
especially now i'm finding you got to
let them know you got to reach out and
then it's nice to get that
heart emoji back
or whatever you get back even if it's
full-on dialogue you know sometimes
texting is a gift not a curse on
saturday one day before he died saget
performed a stand-up set at the ponte
vedra concert hall in jacksonville
florida after the show he shared this
selfie from the stage writing that the
audience was really nice noting the
positivity quote very appreciative and
fun audiences i guess i'm finding my new
voice and loving every moment of it to
be able to just entertain and
make people laugh and do something just
for the sheer joy the orange county
sheriff's office confirmed saggett died
on sunday in his hotel room at the ritz
carlton in orlando florida a cause of
death has not been released at this time
but police add there were no signs of
foul play or drug use he was 65 years
old
[Music]
following news of his death the late
actor's family said in a statement to
e.t
we are devastated to confirm that our
beloved bob passed away today he was
everything to us and we want you to know
how much he loved his fans performing
live and bringing people from all walks
of life together with laughter he is
survived by his wife kelly and his three
daughters from a previous marriage aubry
lara and jennifer of course saggett's
friends and former co-stars like john
stamos candace cameron beret jody
sweeten and mary kate and ashley olsen
were quick to honor him and members of
the comedy community like chelsea
handler amy schumer and adam sandler
just to name a few paid tribute to
sagitt on social media it was just so
shocking to lose somebody like him
because he was such an active part of
our communities because he was such a
supportive part because he was such a
fan of comedy as well as being a great
comedian and so it's very
jarring fellow tv star and veteran
stand-up comedian margaret cho also
opened up about sagitt's legacy during a
chat with e.t shortly after the news
broke he loved the art form he loved
performing he loved other comedians
i think all of that kept him really very
useful and he was still very much a
player in the the business of it he had
so much more to give in so many ways not
just in front of the camera also but
behind the camera as well as a director
as a producer i think that he will be
really seen as somebody who really
loved comedy as much as he was loved
what a great thing what a great person
he was just so naturally funny naturally
ridiculous and
you know it's really it's really sad
i'll miss him a lot close friend and
fellow comedian gilbert gottfried shared
this recent selfie with sagitt on
twitter writing that he is quote still
in shock over the news he was a funny
guy a nice guy
and you know easy easy to talk to and on
monday gottfried reflected on sagitt's
life and career he'll be remembered for
all the people who watched him over the
years
full house and funniest videos and the
people who knew him will remember him as
you know a great guy
really funny really quick
and it was always uh fun if you had to
sum it up in one line what would it be
funny and lovable on screen and off